When Tim Burton's The Nightmare Before Christmas
premiered in October 1993, it did so with
surprisingly little fanfare for a film developed
by Disney.
It was only after the film left theaters that
it began a transition from beloved cult movie
to cultural phenomenon.
The story of how this creepy classic came
about is just as interesting as the film itself.
Here's the untold truth of The Nightmare Before
Christmas.
It comes from a poem
Burton originally penned the movie's story
as a poem when he was working as an animator
for Disney, which he likened to being stuck
in a prison.
Burton could never adapt to the style preferred
by Disney, which became clear to him while
working on the 1981 feature The Fox and the
Hound, saying
"I couldn't draw those four-legged Disney
foxes.
[...] Mine looked like roadkills."
Burton left Disney but kept in touch with
another struggling animator, Henry Selick.
Burton shared his haunting poem about a skeletal
figure named Jack Skellington with Selick,
who showed immediate interest in directing
a feature version.
Production started in 1991, but not without
some trouble.
Selick didn't even have a full script in the
beginning; All he had was Burton's best wishes
and a few of Danny Elfman's songs to go on.
Disney got scared
Disney initially considered turning Burton's
holiday themed poem into a TV special or a
short film similar to Vincent, a 1982 short
film also based on a Burton poem, but had
backed out.
The success of 1988's Beetlejuice and 1990's
Edward Scissorhands gave Burton enough negotiating
power to arrange a deal with Disney and the
project was finally greenlit, with Burton
acting as a go-between for the studio and
his director.
But after seeing the first trailer, then-chairman/CEO
Michael Eisner decided that The Nightmare
Before Christmas was just "too dark" for Disney.
The film was sent away from the kids table
to Touchstone Pictures, where Disney kept
content they didn't want associated with their
child-friendly brand.
What's wrong with disembodied legs and children
with sewn-shut eyes, anyhow?
Isn't that basically their slogan?
Filming took over three years
Hailing from before the days of slick CGI,
the effort that went into making The Nightmare
Before Christmas was intense.
The film was shot at 24 frames per second,
which meant that the characters had to be
re-positioned 24 times for every second of
film.
It took a whole week to create just a single
minute of footage, and eight camera crews
worked at once.
It wasn't just a case of nudging a figurine
slightly, either.
The characters had to be carefully disassembled
and reassembled for every frame so their facial
expressions matched what was happening onscreen.
The Pumpkin King had more than 400 interchangeable
heads alone.
Oogie Boogie was trouble
Despite being a burlap sack filled with creepy
crawlies, Nightmare's antagonist Oogie Boogie
was actually the hardest character to create.
His complex demise in the film was particularly
tricky to navigate, consisting of four shots
that each took a full month to make.
Not only that, but the metal armature inside
the huge figure was so strong that animators
had to get behind it and push it into place
for each shot, so it's no wonder he's barely
in the film.
"Well, well, well!
What have we here?
Santa Clause huh?
Oooo I'm really scared!"
Some viewers also felt that Ken Page's portrayal
of the villain verged on racist.
Selick defended the character, insisting that
Page modeled his voice performance on Cab
Calloway.
This argument is supported by the fact that
some lines of dialogue are lifted directly
from the 1933 Betty Boop cartoon The Old Man
of the Mountain, starring Calloway.
"Whatcha gone do now?"
"I'm gonna do the best I can."
"What are you going to do?"
Composer Danny Elfman has a long history of
channelling Calloway as well, as he did in
the 1980 film Forbidden Zone.
"Well son let me tell you I'm so pleased to
meet you.
The boy and I have been expecting to greet
you."
Best friends for never
All of Jack Skellington's songs were composed
and sung by Oingo Boingo frontman Danny Elfman
himself.
That's Nightmare trivia 101.
But Elfman also recorded all of the Pumpkin
King's speaking parts, too.
While he nailed the singing, Elfman's voice
acting just wasn't up to Selick's standards,
and in the end, Burton and Selick decided
that they would have Chris Sarandon re-record
the scenes.
Elfman took it badly, refusing to score Burton's
next film, Ed Wood.
Elfman still got his speaking voice in the
film, kind of.
The world-renowned composer also voiced The
Clown with the Tear-Away Face, and Barrel,
the smallest of Oogie Boogie's miniature henchmen.
"Whatever you say Jack."
Creator cameos
In the end, Elfman's voice being in the movie
just wasn't enough, and he had the animators
create a shrunken version of his head and
hide it inside a cello.
Tim Burton's severed head was also supposed
to appear in the film's finale as a hockey
puck, but the projectile was changed to a
jack o'lantern at the last moment.
Rumor has it that Disney deemed the inclusion
of their former employee's head a step too
far and leaned on Selick to change it.
Doctor in disguise
The biggest reveal from the unearthed storyboards
was a twist ending.
When Oogie Boogie's sack starts to unravel,
it isn't just worms and spiders that come
spilling out; Doctor Finkelstein is in there
too.
"Yes Jack Skellington it's me!
Me, the man who created Sally from bits of
flesh and scraps of cloth.
But she loves you Jack, you oblivious twit!"
A defiant Finkelstein explains that he wanted
to "teach Sally a lesson" before declaring
his intentions to make a new creation and
disappearing through a trap door.
The Doctor's gross new creation can be seen
in the film's finale.
Why anyone would choose a wife that looked
exactly like themselves is anyone's guess.
But those reasons are probably pretty weird.
Lost voices
Like Chris Sarandon, many of the film's voices
weren't the creators' original choices.
Burton had worked with Vincent Price on two
productions prior to Nightmare, but their
collaboration on Nightmare had to be called
off unexpectedly.
Price came into the studio to record the voice
of Santa, but when the veteran actor was too
depressed after losing his wife, they were
forced to consider alternatives.
James Earl Jones had discussions with Elfman
that ended in an angry shouting match.
In the end, Ed Ivory, a relative unknown,
was entrusted with the part.
Patrick Stewart was also brought onto Nightmare
early on in its development, recording a film-length
adaptation of the poem.
"I'm sick of the scaring, the terror, the
fright.
I'm tired of being something that goes bump
in the night."
In the end, it was decided that the opening
verses would be better recited by the film's
Santa, and the Stewart version ended up on
the cutting room floor, DVD extras, and the
film's official soundtrack.
Horror veteran Christopher Lee also read the
full-length poem for the film, but was also
ultimately cut, to his disappointment.
"I'm sick of the scaring, the terror, the
fright.
I'm tired of being something that goes bump
in the night."
But, as we all know, Lee is no stranger to
being stabbed in the back.
Skeleton babies
The last that Jack and old Sandy Claws see
of each other is when Santa flies out of sight,
leaving Halloween Town under a blanket of
snow.
In an unused epilogue scene, however, Santa
reveals that he actually visited his old friend
Jack years after their holidays disastrously
crossed paths, and found him with a handful
of musically inclined children by his side.
"So, many years later I thought I'd drop in,
and there was old Jack, still looking quite
thin, with four or five skeleton children
at hand playing strange little tunes in their
xylophone band."
Those kids actually sound a lot like Oingo
Boingo, now that we think about it.
There's kind of a sequel… and a prequel
In the mid-2000s, Capcom released a video
game called Oogie's Revenge, which takes place
after the events of the film.
Jack gets bored with his life again, Oogie
is sewn back together by his trio of henchmen,
and the burlap sack decides he wants to be
the king of all holidays, not just Halloween.
The game ends pretty much identically to the
film, with Oogie once again defeated and Jack
once again re-dedicated to his true calling
of Halloween.
No one said it was a great story.
But there's a video game prequel, also!
The Pumpkin King, released at the same time
as the sequel, actually explains the huge
gaps in the film's continuity.
The conflict and jealousy between Jack and
Oogie is explored, as well as exactly why
Oogie has to live underground in his lair.
Spoiler alert: it's because once again, he
lost a fight with Jack.
Jack's cameos
Burton has declared he'll never create a real
The Nightmare Before Christmas sequel, especially
not one where Jack goes to Arbor Day-Town
or something…
"Excuse me, is this Hanukkah Town?"
"No, it's the Vatican, and I'm Pope Shalom."
but that didn't stop Selick from returning
to the character… twice.
In his 1996 adaptation of Roald Dahl's James
and the Giant Peach, the brigade of mutant
insects face off against Jack as a pirate,
with one even declaring, well…
"A Skellington?"
The skeletal master of horror does his job
pretty well, but that's not even his only
cameo.
Selick's 2009 stop-motion film Coraline evokes
Nightmare in a number of ways, though those
with a keen eye were able to spot a direct
reference.
As Coraline's mother cracks eggs over a bowl,
Jack's grinning skull can be seen inside one
of the dripping yolks.
It's almost a literal Easter egg, but it's
so quick, it's easy to miss.
Others, not so much.
"Bunny!"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!